[Music]
and shocking discovery news submitted by
I love JK more than my mom huh no a
woman was arrested after asking her
neighbor to store a box full of sex toys
that actually contained a gruesome
surprise Oh Lord a dick oh man's dick
Lorena Bobbitt they were used what was
used sex toys they smell them they knew
was used the whole box was used what
would you get why would you bring what
would you go to jail
Oh true good point any more guesses
maybe you donated them to a Children's
Hospital then you'd go to jail
wait so this happened in Spain it's bad
yeah it's fun yeah
did they all rattle okay
[ __ ] off I didn't hear your joke
would you like to repeat you can watch
it I was performing one at the same time
that's why all right so this happened in
northern did you say you were performing
one yeah where yeah no we were saying if
Bunya while you were doing that she
actually said it after you said I did
you should did that's what I didn't hear
oh okay
it really is the end of the day you guys
know how we get okay it's the only like
you two are the only ones holding it
together for us Thanks really mm-hmm
cuz I want to be invited back you're
sure you've been adopted hey [ __ ] too
bad you're in because you interrupted
bar purple unless now you get it you
suck so bad I don't know if you'll ever
be back cuz she made fun of you was
being serious about some like beautiful
charitable thing he doesn't like mm wait
he's serious yeah no one ever knows
though so I'm second I'm second do you
like I think his branding is like a big
question mark yeah logo that's pretty
accurate
that's my no one understands what's
going on with me yeah
I want to be taken serious guy only
sometimes when you want it so do i okay
so back to the story here
so Maria was 61
she gave her neighbor a box and told
this neighbor what 6161 they need sex
toys too especially need sex toys mm-hmm
lowly old [ __ ] so she told her neighbor
uh hey so you know that boyfriend I had
his soos
who's 67 and her partner of seven years
you know how you took off so this box
full of sex toys is just a painful
reminder of him that he left behind so
can you please keep it in your house so
she did for six months until there was
this insane odor coming out of it why
don't they just throw it away yeah uh
she was asked to keep them and it was a
jar of [ __ ] it was a box I haven't told
you what it is yet Hosea slow bleeding
it'sit's a Twilight Zone episode Carmen
I'm scared now
what's in the box what's in the box
Maria exactly Maria Maria tell me what's
in the box Maria it's your husband
Robert what's in the box
Maria sauce Sara Johnson what's
happening everyone in my neighborhood
Maria at the end okay anyway so I'm lost
this was from seven eight I don't
remember anyone in berea you never watch
No
her name is Maria oh no that that phrase
is from the movie seven you can't not
the twilight zone it didn't make that
much time did it first no seven did it
better
Walter of course what's seven the one
with Morgan Freeman yeah Brad Pitt and
Brad Pitt that's one of those movies I
wish I had never seen just so I can
rewatch up the first time again that's
one of those movies that shows me how
how [ __ ] trash my sister is because I
tried to show toward she's like this
shit's boring as [ __ ] does move very
slowly not is so good just cuz
amazing but it moves it moves slowly
like the dinner scenes and oh I digress
but there's building repelling tension
my sister's favorite movie is live for
your die-hard so that just says it all
right so it turns out that when she
opened this box the neighbor after this
horrific horrific stench she discovered
it was a severed head oh yeah so no
that's pretty [ __ ] up
so has Seuss's her sues the former
partner she boiled his head right in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] and wrapped it in foil oh
like trying to trap the odor foil lady
foil you gotta use cling film to trap
odor don't mass cling film yeah thank
you
why did this don't [ __ ] give that to how
biggest box full dildos full of human
hair big-hearted [ __ ] to that
picture no no I would warn you so Maria
s soos you don't know what if they're
like [ __ ] 411 they might not be that
big of a head out head yo even if
they're short look at the Casio around
her wrist
you can tell my biggest [ __ ] oh it's
clinging on for dear life and you can
tell by the proportion of the
cinderblock beyond I don't like people
yeah so she got arrested after the
neighbor like reported it what they said
what about us what about us he doesn't
like he said I don't love to be I don't
like people I was like well what about
us paramedics look mm-hmm this is the
cross for you vampires they need Jesus
she cut his head off and she that's a
lot of work he's fat us book yeah dude a
spine is hard to cut through what the
fog you gotta find like the right divot
between how do you know so much she
walked they push my hops her husband
cook it's the same as butchering a pound
cutting through bone is not [ __ ] ease
no it's not you oh you always have to
find the joint
you can't just straight up cut and you
got a severed tendons you need an actual
electric saw to do that you do yeah like
they make handheld ones for kitchen use
yeah not like a giant one professor was
all much blood
what about he's creepy that too but you
could be I mean it's kind of like a man
cut using an axe to cut what you got to
be really strong and know exactly where
to hit what's the difference in Chinese
cleaver in a cleaver if you have I take
you to the market you'll see it's I'm
just asking no issues one has don't be
too so defensive you know the hole that
you used to hang yeah yeah yeah it's not
round it's slanted one smaller than the
other and the Chinese ones biggest that
was amazing oh I'm really impressed
right it made me think I was a cool you
don't know me what was the joke I missed
it she means you'll have to watch the
episode don't forget to subscribe to
subscribe because Casey hasn't been here
to [ __ ] tell us yep so we haven't
been telling people to subscribe sports
DC Sports go
subscribe to just kidding News and Joe
will never miss another geo joke ever
again is that for real don't play with
my heart don't live with their heart I
try my best but you're so far away if
you change we cut your hands let me see
she the back to this crazy lady she said
that she caught him cheating no so she
said that he's gone because he did not
love her anymore
well I guess she could have head off why
does she kill him we know nothing Jon
Snow Joe no Josh no well yeah I don't
know it's just like now they're gonna be
testing the severed head to see if it
was treated with chemicals oh yeah yeah
she doesn't seem sophisticated enough to
think of iodine is she under arrest
she's using Boyle yeah ratchet-ass he
probably left the toilet seat up do you
think she hated her probably do you
think she hated her I just saw I'm gonna
stop my own question but have you seen
the meme where the girls look at surf to
myself where the memes like a girlfriend
like you never put the seat down and
then the pictures like the bathroom
filled with all her makeup and all that
[ __ ] no she probably doesn't like all
women put the seat down no no they don't
question sit down
Oh cuz we're perfect I do you think she
needed the [ __ ] neighbor she's like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] I saw you the neighbor
we just talked about that connection
hates her yeah doing in trouble oh I
know it
what if she [ __ ] the neighbor no no no
I know why so it was because he
disappeared and investigators were going
to her house and that's when and
investigating her apartment and that's
when she put it in a box covered in
wrapping people the funny thing is she
wanted to get it back and save it as a
trophy I'm crazy that's why she couldn't
throw it away they're actually dildos in
the box did she just write dildos on
there for good measure
she told the neighbor so that's why if
you would hope that someone told me what
was in that box
I want to see what kind of kinky [ __ ]
you're into oh whatever like I didn't
open it dildos you're different than
most I would not open a box of sex toys
really one held one wear glove I would
like that want to be like if she likes
those massive ones or the fists or like
the drill go have you seen the drill
dough or the floppy ones what's the
drill bit the drilled all day just like
a drill with a dick on the on the top
I've seen them attached to bicycles like
stationary bikes
oh is it like horror like that yes well
you're riding it and it goes up and down
oh yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah
you say you don't like fighting for me
obviously thought is good when he meets
the right fan until I told you in 30
years
all right I'm not that ancient but yeah
this lady's crazy good thing she got
caught weren't we all though what good
thing but it is a testament to that she
was like if Hades were sex toys don't
check it and they didn't what's your
friend honorable until she put it in the
the Wardrobe in her guest bedroom so not
until that bench came out she should
have told her to put it in her freezer
their sex toys that have to be frozen
that smell never would have come out you
think so yeah if Joe yeah if you freeze
body parts the smell I mean yeah if you
go to freezer meat meat doesn't smell
like anything if Joe came to me and he's
like hey look I got this fan coming into
town
will you take my porn collection I'd be
like let's go get a [ __ ] moving truck
thank you you know who say that's a real
friend
yeah and I would move all my furniture
out of my house including my bedroom a
lot I put it all into swords container
and then I take your whole port
collection that I fell by living here a
my dining room my bedroom my kitchen I
think that's to say my office we're
gonna have to use Barton Nick you will
love that
Oh Bart's house huh yep and then I said
I would I would I would tape it on for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]